[Music]
so which is it
i know bix has a game i know you bribe
quartermasters to leave valuables on the
ships before they come in for scrap but
this isn't that
this isn't something that that pass
no
i went in and got this myself how how's
that possible it was it was sealed on
the imperial naval base in stair guard
look you got the money i got the box
what else is there to talk about i gave
you another thousand credits to tell me
how you got it
another thousand
done
how
you just walk in like you belong
takes more than that doesn't it but to
steal from the empire
what do you need
a uniform some dirty hands and an
imperial token
they're so proud of themselves they
don't even care
they're so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine it can't imagine why
that someone like me would ever get
inside their house
walk their floors spit in their food
take their gear
to steal from the empire
[Music]
you just walk in like you
belong they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine
that someone like me
would ever get inside their house
cassian ander
the empire is choking us so slowly
we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is this
wouldn't you rather give it all
to something real
[Applause]
[Music]
i need all the heroes i can get
for the greater good
call it what you will let's call it
war
it's fermenting out there some
pockets of fermenting
you're in my net
are you a fish
or are you a thief
[Music]
you're slipping
i'm not sleeping
i've just been hiding for too long
as long as everyone thinks i'm an
irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really
doing
this is what revolution looks like
i'm tired of losing
[Music]
you